data security is everybody's business
there are a number of security
solutions out there there are a number
of security products driving these
security solutions
and certainly the security teams are
always inundated with
too many alerts uh too many products and
too many solutions to keep up with
data security is a is a constantly
evolving
and a moving target so when we talk
about the challenges of data security
it's all about having an understanding
of what data an organization has
understand what are some of the
compliance mandates the organization
needs to comply with
and more importantly be able to get to a
more proactive state where
organizations are managing and
remediating security threats as they
arise
and that's really where zero trust like
frameworks come into picture
xero trust ensures that you are
verifying everything and not really
banking on trusting anything without
verification
privacy and data security and governance
are interrelated
there are two phases of the same coin in
the sense that
privacy is something that you could
drive with
having a robust data governance process
and having
a very solid framework to enforce
data governance from a security point of
view and that's really where data
security solutions come into play
ibm believes the current state of data
security
can be improved we believe the market
from here
goes towards more of an open and an
interconnected
space where security solutions could
talk to each other
and essentially enable security
orchestration and response
in a more congenial and more homogeneous
way
and ibm security solutions are built
using some of the security first
principles like separation of duties
being able to deliver data centric
security controls
and ultimately drive all this in a way
that is
enabling security teams to manage data
security threats
and prioritize actions and remediation
what that provides is the ability for
organizations to have their teams
across the board from compliance to
privacy
from risk management to applications
infrastructure to operations
all come together to address business
challenges and particularly data
security threats and events
in a more collaborative way my name is
rajesh vinkata subu
product manager ibm security and
responsible for data security and
guardium data protection
you